not one penny
this is how much funding hillsdale
college receives from the government
not even indirectly in the form of
student loans or grants
not one penny there are
thousands of colleges and universities
in the u.s
the vast majority receive around 30
percent of their revenue
from government funding loans and grants
in other words these schools are
dependent on the government to stay in
business
and they receive more than 150 billion
dollars per year
from taxpayers to do so in contrast
hillsdale refuses all government funding
why the answer is simple money from the
government comes
with strings attached do's and don'ts
restrictions and mandates that in small
but significant ways influence how a
school operates
and educates but from the very beginning
in 1844
hillsdale has been committed to
providing a world-class education that
upholds america's founding principles
and preserves the blessings of civil and
religious liberty
therefore everything hillsdale does from
the private loans
grants and scholarships it provides to
97
of its students to the completely free
online courses it offers
to millions across the country depends
on generous donors
who recognize how much independence is
worth
not one penny safeguards the college's
mission
not one penny preserves the quality and
integrity of a hillsdale education
not one penny ensures that hillsdale can
continue to be a beacon of independence
for all of its students on campus and
across
america